[Music]
coming up on this week's show Alex finds
out how music can stimulate the brain
and boost our focus we take a look at a
self-driving boats but would you put
your trust in one and in our games
review we're saving the galaxy with this
team of intergalactic superheroes
welcome to swipe now first this week it
can be hard to keep up with all the tech
and gadgets claiming to reduce stress
and boost our productivity but what if
the answer lies in centuries-old
classical music well that's what
researchers inspired by Albert Einstein
Clayton and Alex have been to meet them
to find out more okay so if you're like
me you've probably spend most of your
day with a device or another passed into
your hand and whether it's updates push
notifications tweet messages or even
bounce the old-fashioned phone call
there's always something to distract us
so the temptation is course to plug in
and try and drown it all out but what if
the music we're listening to is having
the opposite effect
[Music]
composers and neuroscientists in the
States think they can prove just that
their solution a new genre of music it's
a hybrid of Barack string quartets and
contemporary electro trance what exactly
is wrong with listening to your favorite
songs to get motivated if you listen to
music you like while you're trying to
work it's actually going to distract you
because music you like is designed to
engage you so if you think about
anything you like say it could be Snoop
Dogg the Beatles doesn't matter if you
listen to that music it's gonna be
actually going straight in your ears
straight into your area of your brain
which is called the limbic system where
you feel the emotions and those feelings
and those wanting to sing along with it
is actually going to distract you it's
actually going to divide your attention
will and John both have a background in
the composing chart hits what they've
created here is effectively the opposite
now you might not have heard that one
that whole track is going down since and
they kind of blended together in just
the right way but what you're getting is
a certain pulse at a certain tempo then
when you break it down into Hertz or how
many beats per second are happening you
have a theta state from eight Hertz to
14 Hertz and we know this from five
years of research yeah so these data
there's a very specific speed and what
that is doing is that is additionally
helping your brain get into a flow state
when you're working the music must have
grabbed or thrill you that's distracting
but it also can't bore you like a Buddha
sleep wills team claim their tracks
strike the balance you need to stay
zeroed in on the task
their inspiration came from none other
than Einstein himself a famously called
his violin Lena his brainstorming device
and chalked up much of his success to
listening to Bach and we're gonna start
by getting these electrodes a little bit
more alive with a little bit of water so
with all that in mind I couldn't resist
giving it a go
John's hooking me up to a device which
uses electrodes to measure activity in
my brain my challenge to write a short
article for the first draft I'm allowed
to use my own playlist but a second I'm
trying some of wills new music now this
is far from a perfect test but still the
results are interesting we can see here
just like Einstein what we know about
Einstein is he was both very creative
and very analytical and he was able to
combine these skills in a way that was
unusual at the time and still I think is
very unusual here just when it switches
to the focus it will genius music we
have the synchronous activity the left
and right are going up and down together
so obviously this is a snapshot isn't it
how accurate is this kind of information
and what would you know what's the next
step in terms of really locking this
down as a scientific discovery well we
know from these 1,800 people is that
they perform better at these tasks when
they listen to this kind of music and
that's great what we'd like to know is
what's going on in the brain so that
you're right this is exactly a snapshot
if we were going to do this
scientifically moving forward right we
would need to make sure we have lots of
controls so someone sitting in a room
just writing and silence someone sitting
in a room and writing with different
types of music you know perhaps not just
a six minute experiment with one person
so you mention Einstein there and
obviously how Einstein's brain works
right you see any similarities and yeah
there's certainly when you were primed
just like I'm saying would prime himself
with his with his violin playing to get
into a flow state when you were primed
to get into a flow state your brain
absolutely came together
you're very kind Julia but you know I
think I think we'll probably have to
leave the comparison there
now before we take a look at her
self-driving boats
here's a roundup of this week's tech
news Facebook boss Mark Zuckerberg says
the social network needs to improve the
way it responds to violent videos after
a man posted footage showing him
committing a murder
speaking at the f8 Developers Conference
in California he vowed Facebook will do
more to prevent tragedies like it from
happening a new robots which can make
the microscale movements needed for
delicate surgery could soon carry out a
cataract operation the AXI system
developed by cambridge consultants is
designed to operate on the eye with
greater accuracy than a human this is
rodrigo operating the controls these are
three-dimensional joysticks that the
motion of these joysticks are mapped to
the motion of the instruments on the
inside of the eye and an asteroid up to
a mile wide has passed by earth giving
stargazers a rare treat known as Jo 25
it was the largest to come so close to
our planet in the last 13 years passing
within 1.1 million miles a close pass in
cosmic terms now autonomous vehicles are
foraging into new territories in
Amsterdam it's hoped self-driving boats
could be taking to the water this year
with the aim of transporting goods and
people around the city but here in the
UK one company has been testing its own
and we went to see it for ourselves this
self-driving vessel is called the sea
worker 5 developed by ASV global it's
completed over 1,000 days of unmanned
operations and successfully navigated
the seas around the Isle of Wight
without assistance this is one of ASV
Global's C worker 5 vessels just over 5
metres long and it's designed and built
here in Port Chester and it's now a
minion vessel and it has a diesel engine
underneath my feet back here but it's
most importantly it's an autonomous
vessel so it's able to remotely
navigate itself and conduct tasks for
organizations such as oil and gas
companies Royal Navy and others the core
technology involved is really all about
software so we've been developing a
control system for about ten years and
that uses a whole range of different
sensors to have awareness of what's
around the vehicle so it can then plot a
safe path navigate and complete it its
mission will typically use infrared
cameras so we can see at night we'll
also have daylight cameras such as these
here looking forward often to the sides
so we can see during the day and then
it's not actually fitted right at the
moment but normally we'll have a radar
system as well so if the conditions are
poor if it's foggy we're still aware of
what things are around us and what is
this currently being used for this
particular vessel the sea work of five
is primarily used in hydrographic survey
work so building maps of the seabed so
it has a sonar system fitted to the
bottom of the vessel and it will run up
and down lines almost like lowing mowing
the lawn and that will produce a map of
the seabed but it's also been used for
quite a few other applications recently
we're up in Scotland with the Royal Navy
on an exercise called unmanned warrior
in that task we were we were tracking
underwater vehicles with some acoustic
technology from the ocean to outer space
here's Luci with our games review
outlast 2 is the sequel to the horror
game outlast and it's very very unusual
for a horror game in that you can't
actually fight back so you play as an
investigative journalist and you and
your wife are investigating the murder
of a pregnant woman and your
investigation takes you to a sort of
secluded village where all the
inhabitants think that the end of the
world is nigh and as you're a journalist
you can't fight back but the tools in
your arsenal are a camera so like in the
first game you have this camcorder and
it has night detection audio detection
so you can anticipate when there are
gonna be enemies coming and you can hide
outlast 2 is a really cool concept for a
game and it's coming out
this full-throttle remastered is a kind
of shiny
spick-and-span version of the game full
throttle from 1995 which made by
LucasArts you play as been the leader of
a biker gang who's wrongly freed for
murder and it's you trying to clear your
name for the game and it's full of this
you know the classic LucasArts double
fine humor and in this brand-new version
there are things like new graphics
better sound better controls cuz the
game has dated quite a lot so they've
updated it for modern audiences the only
thing I'd say about this game is that
it's pretty short but if you kind of
want that nostalgia trip then definitely
pick it up
Telltale's guardians of the galaxy game
is coming out just before the next movie
so you have time to catch up
you must be placed our Lord and you have
to go around talking to people making a
lot of decisions choice and consequence
very like dialogue focused but that
means you can kind of craft and weave
your own story and the choice is mostly
come in your intergroup politics so you
can be talking to Gamora or drag or
Groot or Rocket Raccoon and sort of not
make alliances but sometimes they'll ask
for things and you can deny them or you
can just choose to side with another
member of your group so it's a way to
really get to know these characters and
that's coming out it's a five-part
episodic series and first episode that
this week that's it for this week you
can watch any of our episodes on YouTube
on demand and mobile and if you follow
us on twitter at sky news white you can
see what we get up to you throughout the
week see you again next time
you
[Music]